ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show here with ben avery our
producer from a temporary studio an
undisclosed location
uh in los angeles california
r.i.p norm out the gate uh the worst
story of the year hopefully in comedy
um you know
uh norm mcdonald passed away one of the
greatest comedians that's ever lived uh
respected by everybody in comedy no
matter what kind of type of comedian you
were or
what
you believed politically everybody loved
norm macdonald you were obsessed huge
fan with norm yeah
but when norm
you know retweeted us i remember that
was like a massive day right i don't
remember what video it was but it was
the oj one yeah i mean he was just a
[ __ ]
that retweet was like everything when
that happened
and then he said some kind things about
some of the stuff we did on twitter and
uh that was awesome and you know some of
the videos we put out and some of the
clips of the podcast he had said
uh good stuff about and that just makes
your life as a comic right
to have someone like that appreciate you
especially because my story with norm is
not it doesn't start out great because i
did uh last comic standing in 2000 and
whatever it never aired
uh and i did my joke and i did well and
it was him it was damon damon wayans and
rosetta yeah and roseanne liked me demon
wayne's like
he was like
not
he was just like yeah he just like
smiled and left
i think he said right on i don't know
what he was just like barely there like
he wasn't
i don't remember anything either way
and then norm was like how many years
you've been doing comedy i'm like four
he's like what it takes 10 years to be a
comedian what are you doing here i was
like
and i remember that was the biggest gut
punch i got in stand-up and i remember
being at the
hilton by uh where they shoot all those
shows by where is that universal city
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was in the
hilton and i was just like
like i couldn't even eat i was like this
is horrible and i spoke to that one of
the comics i was staying with at um
that point and he was like last comic
standing he's like you go in there and
they pay legends to tell you not to do
what you love which is kind of fun
but i got over it i kept doing it and
then he became a fan of us later on and
a lot of [ __ ] we were doing and he was
right you know i was a four-year
five-year comic then it's like you do
need more time to mature um he did some
hilarious [ __ ] this clip is so funny
yeah i was wondering if we could play
this from the view yeah i mean there's
just by the way you can go on
a binge of norm mcdonald stuff because
all of it is funny you will lose hours
of your day
every rant every joke you go back to snl
when he's doing rental i mean just
there's nothing that's not amazing but
play this from the view we don't want
any more murderers i think we should
just go on to the next question
oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah you
know we're not going to you know but i
have no accusations with that that's a
little confusing
let's just let's just go on to the next
book
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either i'm being very
nice okay
be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
listen we don't need no one to get into
this and i don't want to hear it and
this is not the place to make those
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny
there you go
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara i'm not going to ask the next
question i thought it was a matter of
record
okay let me do this okay
i'll tell you what's a matter of record
you will not be invited back if you
don't shut up all right
let's go
what is star jones doing now by the way
like where where did star jones land
it's interesting let's see what is she
up to i think she did like a whole
weight loss thing right
was that the direction she went in star
jones is an american lawyer what is she
doing now
she she left the view in 06 so i mean
to see what she's doing now i don't want
to lose too much of the show
i don't want to be like 30 minutes into
this we're still like yeah we don't
really know
uh so she went from the view to her
original network court tv now rebranded
true tv
um then the final episode of star jones
aired on in 2008 and i don't think she's
done much since well she's in an episode
of the impractical jokers did you know
that oh interesting well it's
controversial because all the jokers
dress up like her
they they put on fat suits and they do
blackface and they all because the whole
joke is that none of them know
that the other three are also star jokes
the uh a fun show uh called the activist
which um
was going to debut on i don't know one
of these networks it wants nothing to do
with this cbs
the activist
uh was announced and it was going to be
a reality competition show
where uh people competed to be crowned
the best activist
in a battle for relevancy on social
media yes yes it was it was something
that i would pitch as a joke
uh cbs decided to actually fund and make
a show where people would compete
compete to be
the best social media
activist
and when i criticize celebrity activism
it's not so much that it's not
that it's i'm not saying like oh it's
not good
i'm saying it's not
real like it doesn't exist
see it's
depending on the way you feel
it might be misguided but
it it's not even happening is my point
it's just people talking
nothing's going on occasionally there's
some
charity or slush fund
that you can't really
trace where the money goes
occasionally there's a fundraiser
where people go and eat nice food and
wear
designer clothing and they all write
checks
and then a portion of that money
gets funneled to something that may help
someone somewhere down the line but it's
not really like direct
action right
um
and this is this is really what it is
and every now and then
hollywood like does something
that's so
heinous
that they have to disavow it usually
they try to defend what they do
even though they're on very shaky ground
like the imagine video people are like
it makes people happy shut up you're a
cynic
you know remember that when everybody
got together in the beginning of the
pandemic when everybody was unemployed
and they ever was shut down and nobody
had a job and the hero nurses we've
heard endlessly about are all supposedly
the nurses found that comforting i guess
i don't know we couldn't get them ppe
they were wearing garbage bags but
apparently seeing gail gadon all these
people sing
help them but hollywood every now and
then just does something so egregious
that they have to immediately go hey our
mistake and retool
and the activist competit it's like the
apprentice for black lives matter
activists
truly no it's the apprentice for woke
activists on instagram like you know the
the tits out you know you we've all seen
the instagrams
every hot chick on instagram and even
most of the hot dudes the profile
pictures like blm
make sure the pronouns are in there she
her
blm here are the tits
that was the show
they said let's find hot
attractive
socially conscious activists
to basically go and fool the world
using cbs
which is a pretty large platform
let's bring on people
to play a trick to play a joke on the
world uh and say that they are
really concerned with activism
but have the time
to participate in a reality show on cbs
in the midst of their very busy careers
as activists
they have the time
to do a reality competition show some
would say it's a frivolous endeavor oh
no no
it's going to get them a lot of new
people
to follow them on social media so they
can continue to do
better activism
okay this is this was the plot of the
show
this by the way you don't realize how
long
or how
shows have to get made there's a process
and i've been through the process many
times and it's never worked but i know
the process there are layers of approval
that you have to get from many different
people it's not just like one person
goes let's do it
this idea had to climb a ladder of
multiple people that had to sign off on
this saying that this was a good idea
also this didn't start yesterday
this idea was not hatched a week ago
which makes me think that this idea
probably came to an executive during the
riots yeah the timeline makes sense the
timeline does make sense so during the
riots
after the murder of george floyd which
was a [ __ ] and like it was an
execution killing of george floyd
and and all of these things are all
figuring out tamir rice this this poor
kid who got shot you know who had a bb
gun and all of these different
things that had made people
really start talking about policing and
rights and all that during this time
someone in the town that i'm in right
now
had an idea for a show
they had they were looking at all these
people on social media remember the
black square i put one up yes i remember
the black square i didn't know i thought
we're all going to be it was going to be
a collage or something didn't turn out
that way the black square after because
you just if you were white the next day
you put you like you were just like hey
man here's the black square cause that's
nuts
i don't want to stand on anyone's neck
because we all know and listen it was a
cia psyop sure but sometimes every now
and then you just go sometimes the cia
psyop is better than people going why
the [ __ ]
did this piece of [ __ ] not post a black
square
you look like you wouldn't post a black
square so i threw up that black square
and cause that was you know people were
really figuring out
how they were gonna like be like hey man
this shit's [ __ ] up
like i'm not i don't go in with the
narrative that all cops are horrible
people but there's a problem right you
can't stand on someone's neck for nine
minutes this is an issue
um around that time
when people were having those
discussions
around that time uh when people were
calling for these ridiculous things that
have been reversed like defunding the
cops and
abolishing the cops when none of that
really works
but around that time someone in in the
town i'm in now uh said there's a show
here
that's what they said they go there's a
show
there's a show
they had to do this
they had to sit in a room and do this
with other executives they had to go
we're so focused right now on positive
change no this is what had to happen and
ben's laughing because he knows exactly
there were tanks rolling down the street
at this time too no no the country was
on the brink of like
i don't i don't want to say civil war
but whatever was going on was
i mean i remember smoking a cigarette in
palm springs i was on a full giannis and
we were watching these riots we were
going this is [ __ ] crazy we're on the
phone for two hours i smoked like two
packs of cigarettes just staring at
these
things it was unbelievable just things
getting lit on fire and it was crazy
during that time someone went you know
we're all you know in a meeting and
maybe it was a zoom meeting probably
nobody's in the office yeah son of zoom
call they went you know
there's just this young generation of
activists
that we really respect
you know think parkland
you know think david hogg emma gonzalez
you know they're young they're hungry
for change
they're smart they're well spoken
they're telegenic
we just feel like th right now this
moment is so important they love the
word moment they're like this moment is
so important
what we want to do is pit these
activists against each other on
television in a competition
setting and have them do
and by the way we haven't even
we have not even gotten god help us
to what the challenges would have been
because in a competition show
there needs to be challenges
there needs to be uh
something introduced as a variable to
see who
survives and who does not
there's got to be remember you know the
at the end of like any competition show
survivor you're off the island
project runway whatever top chef pack
your knives and go going back to the
weakest sling you are the weakest thing
goodbye all of that you're out
so they had to dismiss there was going
to be a way to dismiss these activists i
don't know what they were going to say
it was designed to show this was long
hours and ingenuity that activists put
into changing the world
i mean
what were the challenges going to be
like what i mean by that is this is a
competition right of course so there's
got to be some type because by the way
they had these discussions too they were
like there's got to be some type of uh
competition here
uh otherwise people are going to get
bored pretty quickly
so we need a challenge like we need to
see who like should we drop all of the
people off in ferguson
this was taught this was real
these were conversations that were had
on zoom
by
production companies and networks
should we drop them all off in ferguson
for the anniversary of michael brown's
death and see what they do
would that is that gonna play
should we drop them off in ferguson and
see what they come up with
what will they do
what if they each have to do
memorials to michael brown but they each
it they eat like
like one they all choose them a more
like some are gonna do a parade
some are gonna do like a sit-in
show we're gonna do like direct action
some are gonna do like and and we have
to see who does it better we have small
teams of activists
i mean what was the show going to be
was that
do they describe what the show was going
to be
so this person that was on the show
alicia o'sullivan an ireland-based
activist and speaker who works to raise
youth awareness on climate change she
just wants to bomb protestants
that's not activism
they got an irish
what she told the daily beast that she
was contacted about appearing on the
show by the end of her interview she
recalls she got the sense that no one
quite grasped the concept of activism so
whatever these no they have no idea they
didn't know what it was here's
hollywood doesn't know what activism is
they think it's just another kind of
entertainment
hollywood things activism is just
another way to build a brand
they think it's like skateboarding
they think it's like uh you know
somebody who's like uh
into like yoga they don't understand
that it's supposed to have like an
effect
they don't get it because they don't
want the effect they're living in 10
million houses they don't understand
they think
that like activism is just a brilliant
way to build a brand so they just they
don't get it
they have no idea
they don't
they're like oh you see you're the
activist so you like care
so we love it you're like socially
conscious you're woke you're young
you're hip i'm loving it are you
biracial perfect you have the burden of
educating one half of your family and
the legacy of the other half of your
family love it i'm eating it up
you are perfect you're 23
ivy league educated perfect
grew up in the suburbs but you had
cousins in the inner city and visited
them yes
this is what we want
now the goal of this of course for you
is a book deal and netflix yes
well i want to change criminal justice
for him yeah yeah yeah sure
we all do
but the immediate goal here is we like
to build your socials do we see
merch do we see a clothing line
do we see a clothing line
that's what hollywood is i mean they
just it's not a town
uh built by good people for good people
this person said so this person hogan
they said they kept pressuring me to
answer questions in a very certain way
when i was recounting my personal story
they very offensively told me that i
sounded like a robot i just felt so much
pressure in those moments that i
literally reached a breaking point on
the call and burst into tears i guess
that was the most horrifying moment
because then there was the pleasure on
his face like yes we finally got the
shot we finally got you breaking on
camera yeah well that's what it is this
sounds more like a documentary than a
reality show i don't see any no they've
changed yeah now they've changed from a
reality show to a doctor it's gonna be a
competition
a reality show where they though there's
a winner i saw they had metrics with
social media followers that's kind of
all i could tell yeah no because again
their concept of activism
is social media followers so to them the
rock is the biggest activist
no no and to people in hollywood the
rock is the most successful activist in
america
because he's got 115 million instagram
something like that so he's the most
successful okay so that's the metric
they decide the jenners are the second
most successful activists in america
because it's all based on social media
volume it's great
again if you haven't been in this town
or dealt with any of these people this
comes as a shock to you
right but it doesn't come as a shock to
me
what comes as a shock to me is how
quickly they disown it and you know why
they disowned it because uh who's this
usher
uh julian hugh and priyanka chopra jonas
who's that joe jonas's wife or one of
the fred joe who are the jonas's did i
say fred well there is a freddy one
bonus jonah say he hates being called
that uh i think he just lives in soho
and does crack
the baby jonas what's his name there's
only three though no there is four
interesting kevin jonas joe jonas nick
jonas and then who's the fourth the
fourth i read about him he just he's
just in new york all day and he has
anxiety and he's on tick tock frankie
he's on tig time
he's on tick tock and i think he does
pills but i don't know
so you know what happened they announced
a show now you got to remember these
celebrities all signed on to the show
so they shouldn't be able to get out of
this right because they all signed on
like she signed on because you know they
needed a woman of color they're like
we're gonna go with you
and then they go we're gonna go with
usher and then who's third here julian
julianne ho
who is this just like a
like a american dancer you're like not
like nothing oh she's a nothing yeah
she's nothing she's literally nothing so
they have
she's just there to be white and blonde
hair and sit there and not scare
everybody oh dancing with the stars yeah
the way networks think about julianne
hoes they go we need a white chick in
there so that people don't automatically
feel like they're being brought before a
tribunal of people of color so we need
julian ho who looks like you know some
girl who walked out of a barn they all
signed on to this okay
and um they filmed it
please leak this footage
i want to see you this listen to this
usher priyanka chopra
and julian ho set up for the activist
cbs competition series from global
citizen
and let's read a little bit about the
the deadline release here
and you didn't have to wait long i'm so
excited to announce i'll be co-hosting
the activists we're gonna meet six
incredibly inspirational people paying
it forward in this world stay tuned
cbs and uh producing partners global
citizen announced the format switch
saying the activist was designed
to show a wide audience the passion long
hours and ingenuity that activists put
into changing the world hopefully
inspiring others to do the same right
that was the goal right that was the
goal
however it has become apparent the
format of the show has announced
distracts
from the vital work these incredible
activists do in their communities every
day like making them do three-legged
races or whatever
like
whatever they were gonna do right
making them cook
the push for global change is not a
competition
anymore
i want this show as it originally was
supposed to happen
give it to me as it originally
was supposed to happen
i want a contest
outside of a planned parenthood
that's what i want to see
i want to see
julian ho judging the photos of um
whatever
women and
guillotines or handmade tail like i
could see like somebody doing a handmade
tail thing outside of a planned
parenthood and
like julian hall and usher and priyanka
they're all sitting there and they're
like that was brilliant
it was socially conscious it was now
the handmade still such a big show
and we just love the way that you took
pop culture elements and infused your
activism with it
you remain and then there's just claps
you know and then somebody else you're
like they're like you came out here
with just the law
and you had these tablets it looked like
10 commandments but they were like the
rights of women
we just felt that it didn't connect we
felt that the tablet seemed a little
weird a little religious which is
actually kind of what we're fighting
and i know that you were trying to
repurpose religion for uh you know
obviously a pro-woman moment but we just
felt like it it didn't really it didn't
it didn't work
and we are so sorry but you are going
home
please give me that show i want that
show i don't want a show where i'm just
going to be introduced to these people
no and they're so tone-deaf you think
that they're they were fighting before
this change they were fighting to like
go to kabul like go to afghanistan and
like help people for the season finale
yeah no the executives at cbs were like
we need something big for the season
finale
they would have brought out michael
brown's mother
no i'm not i'm not kidding these people
are so soulless
they are soulless
they would have offered her a lot of
money and they would have brought her
out to crown who's the top activist
these people don't have souls i'm
talking to everyone i've met okay
[Music]
everyone i've met in hollywood that's in
these positions
they desperately want to convince
themselves they're not evil
and they don't they just don't know how
that's why they step in [ __ ] like this
like they don't understand why this
would be offensive they don't understand
the difference between activism and
performative activism they don't get why
activism can't be a competition they
don't understand why having the most
social media followers at the end of the
day doesn't make you the best activist
they don't get it they have no
commitment to changing anything except
their own personal circumstances which
include a newer tesla and a nicer house
that is it they will tweet about
capitalism and about feminism and about
intersectional and they will tweet tweet
and then they'll put the phone down on a
marble table and then they'll drive
their kids to private school that is
what's happening truly you know aoc and
they eat the rich dress i didn't really
talk about it or you know tax to rich at
the met i don't care anymore i can't get
invested i'm not gonna be one of these
people who like police is the price of
aoc shoes all day like these guys sort
of like she's wearing balenciaga boots
like
guys there's more on there's more to
life but it is just funny we've kind of
reached peak satire where aoc because no
no it's my job to be here this is part
of the suffering that i must do i am
it is not easy
like people on twitter were like it is
hard for her to just face the people
she's gonna tax this is difficult i'm
like it's not difficult she was invited
so it's clearly not that difficult
number two she's not throwing a scare
into anybody over there they're all fine
okay
um but she acts you know like a gun like
this is a little awkward it's a little
strange to see all these rich people
with the taxi rich dress but they all
love it because they know it's all so
pretent
sheath underwear dot com how many times
must i tell you about this company they
have the best underwear they have a
pouch
for your [ __ ] and balls so that you can
not sweat
and chafe
all the things that happen
sheath underwear dot com was founded by
a guy named robert patron do you know
robert patron story
i don't think i have it's very inspiring
it's very inspiring
robert patron was a a marine or
something serviceman
do we know army i believe he was in the
armed forces he's in the armed forces
and he served in i
what's funny about somebody making this
sacrifice
robert pageant served in iraq
and in iraq
robert patron served honorably
and that's the story
go to sheath underwear dot com
you'll save 20 if you use the code tim
sheath underwear dot com
save
if you use the code
tim and help a guy
who went to iraq
and served
honorably
and did the right thing
when he got back from iraq he married a
15 year old
girl
and then she disappeared what year was
that because ted nugent did that in the
70s this was recently he got back well
somewhat recently he got back from iraq
he married a 15 year old girl
and then he killed her because he was he
he realized he was gay
sheath underwear dot com
use tim as the promo code save 20
buy the underwear folks supports us
folks everybody is doing business online
now you don't have a choice
and you don't want to focus on shipping
your products whatever you sell if it's
junk from your attic if you're an artist
if you do crafts if you ship memorabilia
you need to have somebody functioning as
your back office
somebody keeping track of the orders
partnering with ups fedex usps all the
major carriers getting you the best
rates
allowing you to focus on the driving
factor of your business the sales
i'm telling you right now if you use
ship station
s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n
ship station use my promo code tim
dillon you get a 60-day free trial how
important is that when you start a
business pretty damn important no matter
what you're selling or where it is
amazon etsy your own website ship
station funnels all your orders into one
simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere even
your cell phone
so if you go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page type in tim dillon you get two
months free when you type in tim dillon
shipstation will manage all of your back
orders make sure that everything is
organized easily accessible you can
really look at your inventory and what
you're doing it's very easy the
interface is great
shipstation.com
enter offer code tim dillon you get two
months free of not having to worry about
shipping for the life of your business
it's fake we're finding out a lot of
these people refuse to take the vaccine
too a lot of these a lot of the
hollywood people yeah well
again they have access to like the best
medical treatment right
like now i have a lot of money so i have
access to better medical treatment now
because i'm fat i would still take the
vaccine because covet is a holocaust of
fat people
and i just paid 10 grand to get into
some doctor concierge service where i
sat there and the guy goes don't have
dessert i said thank you
we that's
literally i i paid like ten thousand
dollars a guy comes into beverly hills
he looks at me he goes your metabolism
is flawed
i said thank you but what's good is
he'll do all the tests to show he'll do
the blood and the sperm and the
spot him i don't know what he tests the
uh you know
your iodine level whatever it is he's in
there and he'll just do the a
the scans and the aortic and the uh
pulmonary
whatever it is he'll get it done
um
but
the thing is these celebrities don't
want this [ __ ]
because they have the best their access
to the best thing and a lot of them are
very in very good shape yes
so they don't want it and then some of
them are a little
you know like like some of them them a
lot of celebs got the celebs that
weren't mentioned in q anon also
got like were in the queued on
they're not like
i've talked to like a-list celebrities
that believe the world is flat
and these are like a-list people so my
point is not
like hey they should all get the vaccine
my point is like anything
that they believe they don't usually
publicly say it because sometimes it's
too controversial and then sometimes
it's like they've literally not done any
they just someone told them one day when
they were on trooms that
the world may be flat and they go hey
man
that makes a lot of sense
because a lot of the people out here
don't know why they're here they're just
hot
and they're kind of stupid and they're
in this town and they have
bazillions of dollars like they blow me
out of the water they just have so much
money
and
life is
odd it's great but it's odd they're like
this is strange and a lot of them get
they're kind of young and like i'm 36
and i just started to do well over the
last few years a lot of these people
they hit when they're young so they
don't really have that like a lot of
them talk about they had like a summer
job for like four months
like shyla buff made a movie about like
what sleeping in a in a like a motel
yeah yeah how long did he do that for
wasn't he on tv at like 11 and i know
his dad was stealing his money and i
feel bad about that but
didn't that end kind of quickly pretty
quickly it wasn't a decade
it wasn't like forever i'm not
minimizing what charla buff would do i'm
a fan of his and he hugged me once in
the comedy store and said i was
brilliant he won't he won't remember but
he's a great kid and i don't care what
he did to those dogs you gotta i'm hey
you gotta get in character
the point is that
i'm saying that a lot of these people
kathy griffin used to have a joke about
jules she's like what do you sleep in a
car for a weekend like
the thing is a lot of them just make
the most out of these stories that
just aren't that
some of them like tina turner that's a
different story she was getting her ass
handed to her okay but a lot of these
people like it's just not
it wasn't that horrible they kind of got
put on pretty quick and they started
making a lot of money so when things
like that happen and you don't know you
got to really start to figure out like
why the world is what it is
like you have to start thinking that the
you you start thinking a lot
about
why
things are the way they are because it's
not like you struggled and worked hard
and got really good at something and
then it happened it's just like you want
a lotto so you start thinking about
things and you start trying to put
things together in your own mind you
have a lot of adult responsibilities but
you may not have an adult brain
and some of the things that these people
get into are not
like based in reality
and i res i respect nicki minaj here's
the thing with nicki minaj she went out
and said hey my my friend
and uh my
cousin's friend got
he was impotent
uh and his balls got really big and
trinity yeah listen
and that's a cartoonish example right so
it lends itself to
um
people making fun of her right it lends
itself to being made fun of totally
understand that but again it's not a
good idea when somebody goes i want to
do more research or i have a question to
go shut up you stupid [ __ ] which is
essentially
what they did and then she uh she went
at that twitch guy she said uh he said
tucker's white nationalist and she went
right i can't speak to
agree with even look at someone from a
particular political party people aren't
human anymore if you're black and a
democrat tells you to shove marbles up
your ass you simply have to
if another party tells you to look out
for that bus stand there and get hit
she's right about that
these these discussions are policed
and
the policing doesn't work it turns
people off
turns people off when she goes i want to
do more research i don't understand it
and everyone goes what are you going to
go to a [ __ ] clinic and do research
you're a stupid [ __ ]
you illiterate [ __ ] i mean again these
are the progressive people that right
you illiterate [ __ ] like these are the
people that are supposedly
and then so you know
i hope every
here's the thing she's too rich when
she's got like 100 mil when you have
that kind of money you start to stray
on a lot of different issues right you
start to stray go to nicki minaj net
worth
80. it's got to be more it's probably a
little morbid even 80 mil
you start to say to yourself hey i got a
few things to say
at 80 million dollars you go
i got a [ __ ]
i got a take
and
people like jumped on her for it
i just i'm looking forward to the i want
every i want all rappers to be
republicans
i i do
i want like mitch mcconnell and little
uzivert to do like things together i
want nicki minaj to have a song with
laura loomer
i'm getting the racks facts rags i don't
want to get the facts facts fact like i
want
just pure chaos
whereas like kanye but you saw with
kanye like connie's a billionaire you
get to a certain level of money and you
go yeah i just i don't want to feel like
there's anything that's off limits to
discuss
to just throw out there
but then of course everybody's like but
you have a platform and you have
influence and if you say something well
then
and instead of analyzing why that is
that these people have all this
influence instead of saying why do we
live in a country where no one listens
to their parents religious leaders or
the government and they're listening to
nicki minaj instead of analyzing that
we just go no you have to say everything
we want you to say because you have this
massive platform and people listen to
you
and instead of going well listen
the family structure has like
disintegrated to the point where
children are like being raised by
popular culture which is a horrible idea
and getting information from celebrities
is not good that being said it seems
somewhat inevitable to a certain degree
so as a parent i guess you should get
between nicki minaj's tweet and your
child
perhaps
if you feel like they should get the
vaccine like what i'm trying to
understand here
is the terror
people are terrified that like we're
losing
nicki minaj like if nicki minaj
has this point of view
god help us
what is next
who will be next
she is a domino to fall
and when it is she falls
then what happens
who will be next
little baby
who's coming that who will next say
global warming isn't real
who's gonna do it
will dj khaled
talk about a border wall
what who's who's next
i think that's part of what this is
they go we can't lose
and you are losing by the way the vmas
had less than a million views like less
than a million viewers people are done
oh the mtv yeah yeah yeah i saw that no
one cares yeah you know what's
interesting about all these people and
you know you sort it to met gala and
somebody made uh
it's weird it's like all of these people
are
some of them are really attractive and
really hot but also we have this very
interesting thing now where a fair
amount of them are sexless
it's actually impossible to have a
sexual fantasy about some of these
people because they don't look human and
they display no human emotions they
display no
humanity where you do to fantasize about
them you have to create everything
because they themselves for whatever
reason
they look ghoulish
and you just can't think of them
sexually they look like an art piece
and this is not specific to the met gala
although it's kind of on full display
there
that was grimes yeah grimes looks fine
but then people want to [ __ ] her because
she looks like the person in the video
game and you know right she looks like
yeah
but what i mean is like you know anna
and dasha over at red scare i
were they the ones who said this i don't
know if i should quote them if they
didn't say it
someone said the rock
[ __ ]
maybe it was a comedian
i forget who said this
but they were talking about the rock and
it was like the rock is just it's
weirdly like
he's so great looking but you don't want
to [ __ ] the rock
there's something weird about it i don't
know who said it
but whatever it was it was a
i don't think it was i don't think it
was red scare
but my point is that
a lot of the people that you see now
for whatever reason maybe it's because
they're so you know they're they're so
enhanced
surgically
or it's that the fashion is wild or it's
that their personnel oh they're all
heavily medicated their personalities
seem like you know like they had a
microchip surgically implanted it i'm
like like timothy chalamet is a perfect
example he should be like good look have
you ever seen anyone
that you felt
was less
biologically like he's an attractive
dude but
do you look at timothy chalamet and go
let's [ __ ]
not really
and it's not that i'm insulting his
looks
he's great looking technically right
he's got a sharp jawline he's got the
hair but he doesn't look like a human
being
he looks like an idea
did you know what i mean can you imagine
[ __ ] or being [ __ ] by timothy
shalom like
can you imagine any human thing
happening with timothy can you imagine a
lunch
with timothy chalamet
can you imagine sitting at a table with
him
while he like he would like play with an
endive leaf like and like you know put
his hand through his hair and just kind
of like kind of be like kind of like
brooding and like he'd like
like i feel like you just keep getting
closer to the table like
[Music]
and i feel like you just makes a sound
like you wouldn't even talk he'd just be
like
like that's a sound you would make like
you'd be sitting there and you'd be like
the the
chicken is good and he'd go
[Music]
he'd be wearing like all white and he'd
just be like
he just they'd give him a lemon he'd be
like i just want a lemon and he'd be
like
is he is he a human being
it's my question i'm not being insulting
no he's attractive and successful i
can't hurt him
i'm not trying to is that a person
is that a person
that when you're having sex with that
person or when you're speaking to that
person is that person alive
that's my question with a lot of these
celebrities are they alive
like if i met you would you be alive
in a way that i would understand
or not
i'm not saying you it has to be
so now the activists they're retooling
it though
and now it's a documentary and when does
it premiere because i want to watch it i
bet it's just as bad as a documentary
and then we're going to talk about megan
and harry because
i am such a fan of megan and harry and i
love
morse celebrities because everyone in
this country hates elites
but and we hate it but we like royalty
apparently look out for the activists on
october 22nd everybody goes what can i
get for someone that's unique well
bespoke post does something called box
of awesome
you can buy this for yourself or a gift
it's a box
which all kinds of cool stuff
forty dollars a box with over seventy
dollars worth of stuff in it no matter
what you're into the outdoors grooming
boozing all kinds of cool stuff to
upgrade your stuff self it's some real
cool dude stuff
are you into nutrition or grooming or
exercise whatever it is bespoke post box
of awesome allows you to tailor make
boxes
so that you're surprised every month
with a box of really really cool stuff
with each box of awesome you're
supporting small business ninety percent
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand
that's really cool too everyone goes how
do we defeat uh you know the big uh you
know corporate uh you know and what i
say to them is 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up box of awesome.com
enter the code to tim dillon at checkout
we get these things and they're really
cool
sometimes they're shaving stuff
sometimes there's uh stuff to make your
home bar cooler and they have autumn
stuff right now like autumn craft beers
coating threads camping the whole thing
yeah i got some cool camping gear i
imagine getting and you don't even camp
uh but i might start now
the minute you start you're off this
show
get 20 off your first monthly box just
go to box of awesome.com and enter the
code tim dillon at checkout
box of awesome.com tim dillon 20 off
your first box it's great for you but
it's also great for a friend
i lose my head earbuds all the time but
i love raycon
why
they're cheaper
they're better they're durable you get
six hours of playtime they look cool
they have different colors
they're cheaper
they're the best
you can do them in several different
modes
pure mode
balanced mode
bass mode three sound profiles to make
sure everything you're listening to
sounds its best with just the amount of
bass there's also an all new awareness
mode for when you need to listen to your
surroundings
how cool is that that's awesome
raycon offers eight hours of play time
and 32-hour battery life there's also a
built-in mic and you can take calls on
your earbuds with the press of a button
raycon starts at half the price of other
premium audio brands that's why i have
them i have them and i love them truly
ed raycon they come with 45 day
happiness guarantee
i'm done i'm never going to buy another
pair of 300 earbuds again i don't need
to no he's easily linked up with
bluetooth who cares
right now tim dillon show listeners can
get 15 percent off their raycon order at
buy recon dot com slash tim that's by
raycon dot com slash tim to save 15 on
raycon by raycon.com
tim
well prince harry and meghan markle
uh my favorite couple i think they're my
favorite couple
and the reason that i like
prince harry and meghan markle so much
is that um
they prove
to me that we have a deep need and a
desire for a certain type of celebrity
i don't know where this comes from
it's certainly
uh
something
that is deeply ingrained in our psyche
we want thee we like
and love
these types of people
we like high-profile
glossy
uh
people that
are are vapid
and don't have much
going on in their heads but think they
do
like they are under the impression
they have big thoughts
big big thoughts
like megan and harry i've listened to
both of them talk
garden variety
retards both of them
she's hot
he's
royal
but garden variety morons either one of
them
just their level of eloquence like i'm
an eloquent person you may hate me
many do
but i'm eloquent
i have a certain amount of intelligence
that i convey
with the broadcast twice a week once
here once on patreon i watched megan and
i watched harry
they were using their emotion
to cover up the fact that they were not
smart
they were not
too
smart
and they were obviously it was an
emotionally charged interview
because they had just left the country
uh they had found out that the royal
family is uh racist
which was shocking
um up until now they had only thought
that the the royal family uh had
murdered harry's mother
but upon
finding out that in addition to
murdering harry's mother they were also
quite insensitive on the topic of race
no good
up until that point you said well
they're just an illuminati death cult
that drink blood and live for a thousand
years and have murdered my fiance's
mother
but
we're gonna give him a shot and let's
see how evolved they are and it turns
out they're not too evolved and i
watched the uh oprah interview and we
talked about it on the show they're just
not bright
so like many people
uh but they believe they are bright
they say the right things they're like
there are so many people in the world
without
yes
there are so many people in the world
without which is why we have to come to
los angeles and live in a
beautiful mansion with round-the-clock
security we got to get a deal at netflix
and make documentaries about people that
are [ __ ]
that's what it is they want to be on
netflix and make documentaries about
people with cleft palates
that's kind of the direction they're
heading in
just like the obamas who got a netflix
deal who should not have no one no
politician should get an overall with
netflix this should be a line in the
sand
nobody they have a production company
too oh well why not yeah they're
probably doing the activists yeah do you
if you doubt for a minute that if by the
way with no backlash if there was no
backlash meghan markle is on episode
three of the activist
talking about
racial sensitivity training
and the need to do it
you know or the need to get rid of
horses in central park or whatever pet
cause that episode three happened to be
about
meghan markle would be on talking about
it um
she's a hollywood actress means she's
ambition she has
ambition um actors are stupid people
they're not smart
very few of them are intelligent and the
ones that are intelligent are much much
older
young actors are and we know many of
them they're insanely dumb to where it's
noticeable have you ever been with
someone who's so dumb it's noticeable
where you look at someone else as if to
be in disbelief at what this person is
doing
if you had lunch with meghan markle
you'd be stunned at how dumb she was not
cause she's black because i wouldn't
think she was black if i looked at her
because she's an actress who is on the
show suits
okay she's an actress harry is an idiot
he's an idiot for two reasons number one
he signed up to fight in afghanistan war
that was a dumb move
you're a [ __ ] prince what are you
doing that [ __ ] for
number two
i know it's heroic i guess after 9 11
but i think he signed up years after
that that's hilarious and number two i
he's still believing this dumb story
that the paparazzi killed his mom maybe
he doesn't maybe just
so she gets them to leave his family she
goes she goes why do we want to stay
here and i get it i'm for them why do we
want to stay here they're racist the
weather sucks the food [ __ ] let's go to
la we'll eat sushi by the pool every day
and we'll make documentaries about
people with cleft palates
he goes well is it is it when their face
is all yes she goes and then every now
and then we'll fly one of them over
we'll clean up their face and we'll take
him to disneyland but we got to get out
of the uk and we got to come to the us
and we're going to go on oprah and then
every idiot in america but he's like but
they're mad at rich people not our kind
of rich people she goes i'm kind of
black and you're an idiot so you just
and you're willing to be emasculated so
you just sit there and eat your own [ __ ]
on tv
i'll tell oprah that they were chasing
me around the royal palace with nooses
and then netflix will open up a suitcase
full of money and we'll go do
documentaries about kids with cleft
palates is it like where their lip is in
their nose yes
yes just google it harry
so that's what went on
and i liked them i i used to not like
them i've now
i have a new thing now for the holidays
i believe everyone and i love everyone
this is positive me i've been too
cynical for too long but i survived
covet
you know and and other than having seven
or eight skin rashes at any given time
i'm relatively healthy i'm in and norm
just died we're losing people you never
know how long you get
so i've decided to love everyone and
embrace i have embraced uh these two
clowns i like them
yes they're grifters yes they're deeply
unserious and they're not that bright
but i respect how far they've gotten
so i am saying yes to them whereas in
the past it would have said no i would
have said no they're exploiting they're
listed oh shut up who cares they're here
and it's fun
watching people fawn over them we like
royalty we love it we like rich people
stop pretending you don't like rich
people
stop pretty the people that tweet about
marxism all day then talk about how much
they love the real housewives you just
can't quit it and nobody is a realer
housewife than meghan markle who married
this ginger [ __ ] and took him out of
his racist family so that they could
live in beverly hills or wherever the
[ __ ] they live and make documentaries
about people without hands
on netflix
netflix by the way who's committed to
just giving these people anything they
want whenever they want they're making a
cartoon what is the cartoon about
it's called pearl yes it's about a young
girl who is inspired by influential
women in history and counts david
furnish and liz garbus among executive
producers
uh yeah i guess that's it the
12 year old girl who's inspired by
influential women in history the series
currently in development it's all the
information we have that's it
uh she's on a journey of self-discovery
as she tries to overcome life's daily
challenges says well that sounds great
good for her man do you know how many
actresses
that do a show like suits just get
thrown off out in the street
afterwards megan markle parlayed that
into a [ __ ] royal wedding and then a
year in or a couple years in said [ __ ]
that [ __ ] and left and i'm not saying
the royal family was not racist to her
i'm sure they were but that also didn't
start when she got there
they didn't like become racist
she knew like it started probably early
on when they confused her for the help
nine times
they're probably ordering tea from her
an exciting tale that weaves together
fantasy in history pearl focuses on a
young girl who learns to step into her
own power when she embarks on a heroic
adventure and meets important women from
history along the way
we're excited to develop this adam and
shares with our partners at archer well
productions and story syndicates there
are 12 productions that's that's good
yeah archwell production so you know
what this is going to be like pearl's
going to go back you know there's gonna
be a scene
where pearl's like
who are you
my name is harriet
harriet who
harriet tubman
we got a railroad and you go oh my god
this is the underground railroad
yes it is
this is so amazing i can't believe it
you're so brave and strong yes i am
child but i'm not nearly as brave and
strong as meghan markle
who's that she was an actress on suits
it's a tv show
yeah
she married prince harry
you know the son of that woman they
killed
in a in the thing in the tunnel and they
said the press did it but you know it
was good cause she was gonna marry dodie
alphayet he was muslim it's a whole
thing it's oil
saudi arabia whatever you gotta follow
cynthia mckinney on twitter
what
anyway
i'm just saying
yes um where's cynthia mckinney at the
met gala by the way that all she did was
talk about 9 11 all day where's she
where is she where is she
well here's what i'm saying child
i'm saying it i may be brave but the
bravest person ever is meghan markle
thank you
i'm excited for that show
i'll never get another special on
anything ever again like
i will i will my special will be on like
pepboys.com
i mean
it will be like it will be so far
every day i hear about like another
executive who genuinely hates me who
like brings me up by name
in meetings that they do not like me
i'm we're selling so many tickets with
this the show's gotten so massive
and uh the offers have been slim
slim to none
but that's okay and then people ask you
to go do you think
that's special i go i don't know maybe
i'll do reach out let's reach out to
harry and harry and megan
let's call my agent right now
on the air
and ask him if he can reach out
let's see if
hey quick question i know it's late
you're probably
i figured you're up with a kid is there
any do we think that there's any way
that archer well productions might like
produce my special that's the production
company founded by meghan markle and
prince
tweet about that harry amazing no but i
mean can we give me a meeting like i
think i should get a meeting with them
i love it why not we should you know
what we should do is we should try over
email and then i'll forward you the
emails and you can post it or whatever
yeah do that do that
you know if vote please pursue this
please all right thank you brother get
some sleep
that's what i like him because he he
he'll get fired too
he doesn't care
you know what i mean
i mean with his clients i mean he could
do his job you know out of a rehab
you could just sit in a
archwell productions i want the duke and
duchess of sussex
do you does anyone
not like this idea though seriously the
duke and duchess of cambridge present
tim dillon
i love it
it's great
we we could do it over there we go
overseas and do it no they're here oh
right right we do it here but they can't
we can't go there anymore because
they're racist right because they're
racist there they came to a country with
no racism america
because the royal family was so racist
they came to a place where the you know
we have the least racist organization in
america right here in the city the lapd
no no none of this was a plot this was
all well thought out
made sense
is it lo with the clever palette is it
when is it locked a bit in apple but it
got stuck
please google it for him someone
alright
are we going to see oprah
can i meet lizzo
stop asking me questions you're really
[ __ ] annoying me today
okay we're doing it we're doing we're
skyping right now
with uh
the leader of [ __ ]
some country we're about to demolish
for a tv show
archer well productions
these people have me whacked
they'll have me done diana style
they will do me in diana style yeah
they'll whack you
we should have spent more time on uh 9
11 this year but we just kind of let it
go by yeah
what are you gonna do yeah you can't
here's the thing how long can you
discuss something it's a good question
doesn't mean it's not important you
don't care anymore or that i'm a
hollywood elite you're a hollywood elite
how many what are you gonna do
how many times are you gonna ring the
bell
you know i don't you know
yeah man
i just think there's a very slim chance
we're getting to the bottom of it
i don't think
i don't think we're getting to the
bottom of it
you'll straight up go i don't know your
kids will ask you what happened on 9 11
you will straight up at the kitchen
table go i don't know go to school
ask them i pay taxes let them ask you
what you're doing
people said i was gonna have a non-line
did you ever listed up a podcast episode
that last podcast on the left did about
911 that was like a three-parter it's
like a nine-hour epic never ever listen
i've never listened to that show but i
mean i have friends that love my friend
ryan from long island loves less
podcasts on the left and i know ben and
i know henry
and i've known marcus
but i've
never really listened but i heard that
it was like the best thing ever it was
insanely well researched
the documentary is 9 11 the new pearl
harbor if you want to watch your
documents a fun four or five hour thing
yeah it's amazing show the kids
it's fun
archerwell productions presents the
activist
on this episode of the activists we have
a special guest please welcome meghan
markle that's like project one runway
like all the activists are standing on
the stage and like oh my god
they're like it is a dream to meet you
and meghan markle's like today's
challenge is this a school boy with a
water gun was shot in the face
and everyone's like this everyone's like
oh no
they're like by three racist detectives
we've got 48 hours to come up with a
strategy including a slogan
merch a big social media push
live direct action sit-ins parades and
music i need you guys to be utilizing
everything all of your celebrity
contacts all of your big social media
names the name of the game here is cross
marketing we need to have a [ __ ] we
need a fund setup asap we need to start
[ __ ] filling that with money so that
we can get these events off the ground
okay now remember i don't really know
the kid's name but it's about him and
they're like yeah
yes it is
yes
so there was like
he was shot in the face yes so in the
slogan i think we should use the
visceral nature of the horror of what
happened
so then it'll cut to them they'll be in
like confessionals and be like as soon
as i heard
shot in the face i knew i had the
perfect slogan
if it's in the face it's about race
it was brilliant i knew you won right
there
when you came out and then at the end
when they're doing the judging they're
like
when you came out with if it's in the
face
it's about race
we knew immediately that we had a winner
and they're crying thank you so much
megan i love you
they're like listen
it was brilliant the chanting was
brilliant your direct action was great
when you screamed in the face of that
crossing guard and put it up on
instagram
you know
the the merch wasn't exactly what we
wanted we didn't love all of the designs
and we thought they were a little too
visceral
you know and they were like yeah i
shouldn't have went with the with the
gun and with the face and the gun
something more like and they're like we
find it's like nina garcia's a different
project runway
we find when the event is incredibly
heinous we do more symbolism everyone's
like yes
they all nodded each other like they're
getting the wisdom they're like yes more
symbolism that makes a lot of sense
thank you so much
megan's like thank you so much you're
all so brave to be here on the cbs lot
filming this show
but that's what it is and god i mean god
can you believe the finale
like what they would have done for the
finish oh man like the levels of
depravity that they would have sunk to
for the finale
the levels
of depravity
that they would have sunk for the finale
like the things
they would have pitched maybe not done
or got the green light to do but the
ideas
that they would have thrown out there
would have been so horrible
and and so grotesque
because you're like we got to pull out
all the stops
we got to pull out all the stops
you know
they're like we want everything
there are only two activists left
today
is the final decision to see
who'll be
the best activists in america
take your blindfolds off
look around
you're standing in minneapolis minnesota
not a few blocks away
from the birthplace of this movement
where george floyd was killed
there's a chest in front of you
in that chest
there are two boxes
pick one
the box will open
and you will have
different things you can use for your
final project
some will be phone numbers
of george floyd's family
some will be addresses some will be
pictures
some will be pictures of racist gangs
that have infiltrated the minneapolis
police
please join me
right now
and they would bring out they'd bring
out like
a ton of people they'd be like please
welcome
our celebrity
judges
michelle obama
greta thundberg
and michael brown's mother
you have three hours
to complete your challenge
which is making a collage
to show
how far
we still need to go with race relations
your time starts
now
man
and they would have done it they would
have done it all they would have done it
all but the people unfortunately got in
the way of that because let me tell you
right now there's nobody who understands
um humanity less than the people whose
job it is to showcase it for you on
television every night
nobody understands the human condition
less than the people whose job it is to
bring it to you um we're on tour
timdylandcomedy.com
uh we're adding second shows in atlanta
we're adding a second show in san
francis sacramento we're adding a second
show in atlantic city uh we're adding
second shows all over the place things
are selling out thank you guys we
appreciate it
the vax mandate [ __ ] is wild uh some
some of them you could bring hopefully
you could just bring a negative test if
you don't want to be vaccinated every
comic in the world is having to deal
with this right now
it's [ __ ] annoying hopefully this is
over sooner rather than later
um and this insanity
does not persist you know i've always
said it doesn't make a ton of sense to
me that if you can get and spread coven
why you need
uh
to show that you have the vaccine it's a
weird
it's strange i think it's a freak out
that people are having i think that ends
in a few months and i think people
hopefully forget about this and abandon
this um i could be wrong about that
after 9 11 no one abandoned anything
um
but
i just think three years from now and no
one who's still gonna do this no when
there's no you know when nobody's had
cover you know who's still going to be
like show me your back yeah like i think
it's just ivormectin well no one's going
to care yeah it's
we're going to move on i believe
there'll be another thing then
that they'll we'll be getting [ __ ]
with
uh but the shows are selling really well
we're very excited to be out there
performing sam talent's going to be on
the road with us a [ __ ] amazing
comedian
timdylandcomedy.com for tickets tim j
dillon d-i-l-o-n on instagram and
twitter
um
if you want to follow me
and um
go grab tickets la
night after thanksgiving at the region
or where no at the
wilton
in l.a november 26th friday november
26th night after
thanksgiving at the will turn
gonna have a lot of fun there i'm
excited about that show excited about
the beacon theater a few tickets left
it's almost sold out
um patreon episodes out every tuesday
uh subscribe to the youtube channel if
you have not
tim dillon's show
we do appreciate that people talk about
merch we don't have any right now
i mean
we'll get some maybe by the holidays but
i don't know
we might do one thing for the holidays
in the winter we might just do one
hoodie something super simple
we don't know what it'll be yet but
uh thank you everybody for buying
tickets we're gonna have
uh
a ton of fun out there
and we're gonna bring
there's gonna be some fun surprises
on some of the shows
and i'm i'm hoping that this ends in a
special
produced by the duke and duchess of
sussex
that's the hope
the duke and the duchess
of sussex
oh let's play this before we go
oh yeah so this is everybody was up in
arms about kensington avenue and philly
yeah we were talking to gillis about
this he says it's rough shane says it's
rough it looks fine to me play it okay
10 million views on this dude i've been
all over this country that's not even
that bad
that's not even that bad
she's got something in the rear
this is fine
alexis everyone's response to this was i
can't believe this is america i can't
believe this is i guess if you haven't
traveled yeah if you haven't gone
anywhere this to me doesn't even look
that bad
it looks like a play where they're all
gonna get up you know like les
miserables
at the end of the day or another day
colder that's all they can save for the
life of the ball
it's a struggle it's a war and we're
hoping that meg and markle and pretary
make a documentary about our lives
because then they'll be better good
night